What will happen to part-time contractors?
if the maximum working day is reduced?
You already know that PSOE and add have reached 1 agreement.
If you govern,
will the maximum working day be increased from 40 hours to 37 hours and 2nd
but what about the 20-hour worker?
Please note that the part-time working day is calculated
percentage above the maximum working day,
therefore,
if it is finally reduced,
you will usually get 1 of these 2 options.
First,
your day is reduced by percentage
and you continue to collect the same.
In this case,
you would go from 20 hours to 18 hours and 45 minutes.
Second,
your workday stays the same but you will get paid more when you work.
more percentage,
in this example,
your salary would go up 1.6.7%.
Stay informed,
follow us